um
i want to talk about post-modernism a
little bit with you guys
one of the i am going to
uh suggest to you today
that
the
often misunderstood
post-modernism
that the right assigns to the american
left
is actually something that we can
correctly ascribe to the right and i'm
going to give you some examples here now
let's back up a little bit
one of the criticisms that the right
loves to make about the left is the
left's woke post-modernism means
anything goes
everybody's opinions are equally valid
everybody deserves an equal seat at any
table we must listen they say the left
says we must listen to any hair brained
crazy idea no matter how uh
unsubstantiated or unbacked up not
backed up it is by empiricism and data
or whatever and that's how the left gets
into these crazy things that they end up
getting into like uh you know all the
different things they talk about and
some of the things we've talked about
right like uh jewish women aren't
intersectional enough to lead the
women's march or whatever the case may
be
now
does that exist on the left to some
degree well yeah it's it's a very very
small thing on the left
but i would argue
that this is a much bigger deal on the
right where when the right says
you really can't trust
the media
and some
guy with a mic
on real america's voice
is
at least potentially just as trustworthy
as actual investigative journalism that
is doing real investigative journalism
or for example
scientists specialists public health
experts
they don't necessarily know what's going
on
some preacher offering you drinkable
silver
or
some dude on the internet who's
vaporizing
hydrogen peroxide all of these things
are equally likely to be
the proper way to deal with covid or
my sister's stepmom's brother's aunts
adopted babysitter
is just as good of a resource on
vaccines as
a doctor that is actually the place
where you see this anything goes as long
as it's convenient type of stuff and
look at this example
here is now you might have been
unaware
that the trucker convoy is kind of like
still i guess going on and some
republicans have invited the truckers to
meet with them and here is video of a
convoy truck lee a trucker convoy leader
saying to republican congressman jim
jordan listen
the truckers know what's going on with
covet covet is over and truckers are the
new scientist and jim jordan loves it
this
is the very caricature of anything goes
post-modernism
that they ascribe to the left look at
this um so yeah we the the countries
figured it all out and yeah they
appreciate the fact that you're you're
standing up and saying the first
amendment matters i mean
becomes a scientist for america and
around the world and there's no science
across the world and these ladies cannot
test it that
supports any of the mandates or the
underlying emergency declarations there
is no death or science
covenant is done
and the american people understand this
omicron was our off ramp
governments need to be bold and grab
over crown and take this exit strategy
yeah sadly enough it takes the trucker
to now stand up as
a scientist right the truckers this
country is going down the tubes
but truckers
doing the work of scientists are what is
going to save us
this is the very
it's a caricature
of the very post-modernism that they
claim to oppose
there's other examples of this
bryce mitchell the ufc fighter last week
i played a clip of bryce mitchell saying
i don't know what's going on in russia
and ukraine and then giving 10
unsubstantiated opinions and conspiracy
theories and tucker carlson brings him
on as someone to be listened to remember
this this is the same thing guys
everybody gets an equal seat at the
table ufc fighter trucker on matters of
geopolitics and epidemiology why the
hell not honored to have bryce mitchell
join us tonight bryce thanks so much for
coming on and for what you said
i i haven't seen anybody express it
better than you did why did you say that
well thank you so much for having me
brother and i said that because that's
the first thing that i thought when he
asked me and i was trying to give him
the best answer that i could and that's
just my genuine thoughts on the subject
how do you get to be so honest when
everyone everyone else is afraid to say
what they think and you just kind of say
it
well i don't have to be
worried about being fired from my job
for saying what i want to say there's a
lot of people out there that do agree
with me but they can't say things that i
get to say even though they thank them
his explanation for how he's coming up
with all this stuff doesn't really
matter but again
they say the left has this anything goes
sort of idea
but it is they who are actually doing
exactly that and then lastly madison
cawthorne and again guy knows absolutely
nothing about foreign policy or anything
and it has worked on the right here is a
guy at one of his town halls actually
saying can you explain russia and
ukraine to me yeah anybody else
yeah congressman yes sir um
we got this mess in the
eastern europe there with ukraine and
all that i know you've made some
reference to uh
president zielinski being a thug or
being you know in the government being
corrupt
we're all i think we're all trying to
figure this thing out i mean
it seems like we're on the precipice of
a
could be a possible major disaster can
you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we stand with that uh i will
so
one and again we already looked at
madison cothran's answer it's whacked
it's outrageously critical of zelensky
it attacks ukraine and does all these
different things doesn't matter the
specifics don't matter but the point is
the right loves to ascribe this exact
type of listen this person is an expert
or whatever maybe
we bro why do you why is a blue-haired
feminist explaining gender when that's
not really you need a doctor i guess to
explain sex and gender or whatever but
then they've got madison cawthorn
explaining geopolitics they've got bryce
mitchell ufc fighter explaining foreign
relations and they've got the truckers
acting as scientists it's absurd and we
can't allow them to get away with
accusing the left of doing exactly what
it is that they do every single day
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything i'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes